Albert Brewer joining us from Chicago
well I'm not Chicago is still in
Bourbonnais Illinois where the Bears are
practicing Albert yeah but it's
definitely not Chicago Bourbon a and I
have I think I have a solution for your
catch no catch thing yes you're probably
I said this was after the dead catch I
feel like and I don't know what sixth
grade rich was like but I know sixth
grade Albert all on the schoolyard there
was never any doubt about what was the
catcher what wasn't a catch when you
were playing touch football or whatever
right like I just knew so why don't we
Park a twelve-year-old up there in the
booth I like it
right yeah 12 year old 12 year old me 12
year old you I feel like we knew it can
always do that was one of the things
that never really got argued like it was
seeds it was you can always tell what
was catching what wasn't yeah but don't
you think everybody realized the 12 year
olds got insight but but that opens up
another door Albert because right now
when al River on the new head of NFL
reps is talking to a ref let's say you
know hockey lay in the stadium about
making a decision you don't need the
says who says me you know and then
sticks to you know what I say bounces
off me and sticks to you like glue we
don't need that sort of stuff you know
right it would it really could delay
things a little longer right right I
just think you know like I said like I
think like the 12 year old can be the
director of common sense I love you know
so it's a 12 year old going to start for
the Bears in week one to use this as an
effort what do you got for me I would
say here's what's so interesting about
it rich is like and I feel like people
forget this sometimes but what the
barest is effectively what Philly did
last year you know and that totally paid
a veteran it's a high-end veteran and
Sam Bradford and then brought in a
backup and chase Daniel and then traded
up twice you get Carson Wentz and yeah
they got lucky on the back end of that
by feeling off by dealing off Sam
Bradford after the Teddy Bridgewater
injury but if Carson Wentz it's the
right quarterback to the next 15 years
no one's going to remember what they
paid Sam Bradford what they paid chase
Daniel and it's the same thing here
you know I don't know whether or not mr.
Biscay or Mike Glennon is the long-term
answer here but I do think that this is
a new way of doing things where you just
throw as many darts and at the dart
board is you possibly
and so resources as a physician because
if you get it right no one's gonna
remember what you got what you want her
to get there well that's true but now so
but you're you're really you're you're I
guess dancing around the third rail here
because the question is is did they get
it right I mean and and list and in you
know when when the NFL Network first
started no one was really talking much
about first practices you had to look in
the agate type in your newspaper to see
anything going on for transactions on
any front now now you're looking at
social media and you got the fact that
true Biscay fumbled the ball three times
and snaps over the weekend so that adds
a little bit pressure to the situation
over no question and that's the thing is
like you know I one of the things I know
that they worked on in the spring with
Mitch was stuff that you wouldn't sing
an NFL quarterback would have to work on
taking a snap spitting out a play call
in the huddle that stuff he didn't do in
high school or college like he's
literally never done that stuff before
and so you know I think part of this is
you know you use 2017 to get answers on
Mike Glennon and the contract allows you
to get out from underneath him if he's
not the answer and in doing that you
also get mister Biscay up to speed now I
look I talked to a lot of teams that
didn't think any of the quarterbacks
this year or first rounders and so the
fact that somebody gave up what the
Bears gave up to go up one spot from
three to two to pick one of those guys
obviously there's doubt there are a lot
of people who don't think the Bears got
it right but you know if you look at
just conceptually and the way it sets up
you know you take a shot at Mike Glennon
who's never had a full-time shot as an
NFL starting quarterback if it doesn't
work you can bail after a year and in
going through that you give mr. Biskit
what he needs which is you know a true
redshirt year in 2017 well I'd let just
John Fox get that same one because I
mean look I don't think that I don't
think anyone stays here right now you
know it's been three years and so you
need to start to see the team turn some
corners and that's you know I think
based on what they inherited you know
what so the upper management knew
that the first two years were going to
be rough this is one you have to start
to see progress and I think for
everybody here that means because Kevin
white get on the field because he was a
high-end tech this is Leonard Floyd what
they thought he was going to be when
they traded up for him in 2016 and so I
think as much as anything else for these
guys to survive and further not to be
changes in 2018 in Chicago you have to
come at least out of this season
thinking okay maybe this could be a
playoff team next year I don't know if
their playoff team right now but at
least those young players need to
develop where you see that sort of
promise coming out of the season where
the mmq B's Albert Bridge joining us
from bears training camp meanwhile in
Baltimore ESPN's Dianna Rossini says
that Ozzie Newsome and John Harbaugh
have given their approval to bring Colin
Kaepernick on but Steve bisciotti the
owner is resistant what can you add to
this Albert I think a lot of its going
to ride on Joe Flacco tell you know and
I know there was an outcry when they sat
in the realtor or whatever last week to
play quarterback but they needed a camp
arm and that's what that was
and you are never going to go through
what you're going to have to go through
to bring in Kaepernick to have him there
for seven to ten days and so I think
part of this is going to boil down to
you know where Joe Flacco's health is at
and that the plan was and we're coming
up on that time now to get him off his
feet for a week and then reassess where
he's at you 32 years old back problems
generally don't go away they can linger
they can pop back up and so you know I
think the medicals on Joe Flacco you
know will sort of help tell the tale
here where you know so the Ravens feel
like you know this could come back up in
October or November and we have a
serious problem here we're going to have
to find a way to create a threat on
offense and Colin Kaepernick based on
what he's done in the past but based on
the fact that Greg Roman is in the
building is somebody who I think they
believe would be able to do that to them
to do that for them in a pinch if Flacco
were to go down so you're saying that
barring a and increased football need
this isn't happening I just think yeah I
mean III think if if you is based on
Colin Kaepernick
you'll know that they're nervous about
Joe Flacco's back so they're so so I
guess then there is a football need
threshold that the Ravens are even a
Welling will that exists that they'd be
willing to undertake this ok so here's
the thing right like and I think this is
the best way to look at it back up a
good job a backup quarterback and
starting quarterback those are separate
jobs right that's why it never made
sense it's just ranked the top six
before the top 96 the backup quarterback
has got to be ready for game day without
getting any reps and practically the
hardest work word you're building it's
got to be a caddie in certain ways to
your starter because that's the other
set of eyes outside the coaching sets
the starters going to have and Colin
Kaepernick isn't a great fit for that
but if he's going to be your starting
quarterback if you're going to need
somebody for six to eight weeks to be
able to create that threat that's
different
he is a good fit for that and so I think
part of this for the Ravens is looking
at it and saying we don't look at him we
don't we're not going to bring him in
here as a conventional backup
quarterback that that's not what he is
you know that's not what he's built for
you know but if we're nervous that could
be a period here where we're going to be
without Joe Flacco for an extended
period of time he is somebody who would
fit as a starter and so if they forecast
that and they say to themselves you know
we could be like we could be up flank
Creek you know in October then I could
certainly see where they say Colin
Kaepernick's the right guy he created
threat for us if Flacco goes down we
want to bring them in yeah the mmq B's
Albert Brewer joining us here our poll
question today is who's winning the NFC
East which is obviously a fluid
situation ordinarily sterling Sheppard
went down it's being called right now as
we're chatting an ankle injury not a
knee injury so we'll keep an eye on that
and then there's the Ezekiel Elliott
situation certainly if you might miss
games and then games against the Giants
no less what is the deal with this or is
the league no to the delete know what
they're doing and they just don't want
to do it well Jerry's getting inducted
in the Hall of Fame what's to you to
appear rich do you remember like how the
Josh Gordon situation dragged out yes
how and I am
I don't remember what year it was but
April and May and then it was what are
they doing with Josh Gordon I think this
is similar to that where you know the
legal intentionally dragged its feet
with these investigations sometimes
because they don't fully trust the
player and the last thing they wanted to
make a decision before they have to and
then three weeks later the player gets
in trouble and the league looks stupid
for taking it easy on them and so I
think that's part of it part of the
equation here was Zeke we're and we've
seen this with guys again guys like
Gordon who have history is okay let's
make sure that he behaves himself and
let's make sure that that you know he
acts in a way that reflects well on the
league and then when we have to make a
decision we'll have more information
so that's where I think Zeke's on shaky
ground here to some degree I mean at the
time since that haven't you the st.
Patrick's Day thing you have the bar
fight and in a vacuum neither of those
are big deals but it kind of plays into
a larger pattern of behavior that I
think is troubling for the Cowboys MOLLE
so we will hear something before the
season not at all I mean yeah before the
season okay I don't I I don't know
there's any rush to do it you know in
the next two weeks Peschel e like you
said I didn't even thought of that
element of it that Jerry's going into
the hall oh yeah they just weekend but
that's different but I mean I guess that
means we're not going to get the Friday
into stuff this week right no no no that
is not happening on the day that Jerry's
getting his jacket put on and the
commissioners in the same building and
know that I don't think Leo but but you
think about it they'll rich I mean like
look you know part of this again like
and a lot of times people say well
that's not fair to the team well I mean
look Zeke had the reputation for
partying coming out of Ohio State the
same way that Josh Gordon had the
reputation for pot coming out of Baylor
right so I mean we can look at these
teams in some cases and say well you
know what you're buying buying into here
so we're not going to give you a break
we're going to collect as much
information as we can let some time pass
and then we'll be able to make the
informed final decision we're not going
to wind up looking bad because of
something that happens a few weeks after
we made a decision a little earlier than
we had to well look I don't like usually
ending segments correcting my guests but
Zeke didn't have those reputations
coming out of Ohio State he had it
coming out of the Ohio State he also had
a ring
[Laughter]
however it is the connection still now a
girl I just don't
Robert I lost you dropped out our you
dropped out over went away do rent on us
take care our I think it right now job
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy